la collecte de données c'est une étape
incontournable d'une démarche
scientifique
mais pour recueillir les échantillons
certains déploient des efforts
titanesques
c'est le cas de guillaume moreau et de
ses cinq compagnons d'expédition en 2018
ils ont parcouru en un peu plus de deux
mois 1600 km à pied et en kano dans le
nord du québec et du labrador
[Musique]
je tue
je
plus je bats est mon projet l'expédition
encore plus je développais mon expertise
en sciences j'étais pas encore vingt
scientifiques je sortais de mon bac en
aménagement environnement forestier
universal et je commençais une maîtrise
et un homme est venu me voir presque en
courant en me disant qu'ils allaient
faire une expédition
je me disais pourquoi mélangerait pas
mon expédition avec la séance confiance
en partie de schefferville ils ont
descendu la rivière de pas puis la
rivière george jusqu'à la baie d'ungava
[Musique]
ils ont ensuite remonté la rivière qu'au
rock pendant 130 km fait un portage de 8
km descendu une autre rivière ou
rejoindre entre l atlantique et pagayer
pendant 600 km jusqu'au village inuit de
nain un périple fou qui les a amenés à
affronter les crues les icebergs la mer
les ours blancs
[Musique]
mais le plus beau c'est que chemin
faisant ils ont recueilli des centaines
d'échantillons d'épinette noire pour la
science l'intérêt pour les scientifiques
c'est que l'expédition allaient dans des
régions où l'on va normalement en
hélicoptère à grands frais c'était une
opportunité d'aller chercher les
échantillons de bois dans un endroit où
on n'aurait pas pu rêver d'aller sans
compter que les arbres que les
aventuriers à les côtoyer ont beaucoup
de choses à enseigner aux scientifiques
parce que sur les rives de l'immense
rivière george il y a des forêts bien
plus au nord qu ailleurs
c'est pas juste des petits arbres
rabougris c'est des vrais peuplement de
forêt boréale qui qui s'en va
directement vers la mort et qui
finalement sera environ 400 km plus au
nord que la limite des arbres
l'échantillonnage de guillaume nous
sommes dues n'est qu'en fait c'est
d'avoir des arbres qui sont dans des
conditions très très limité par la
température donc à la fois on a des
arbres qui ont aussi ils vont être très
très sensibles aux températures mais
aussi on est dans des endroits sur la
planète où le réchauffement climatique
dans les dernières années ont été le
plus prononcé
[Musique]
évidemment l'expédition a eu son lot de
surprises et d'émotions fortes
l'année dernière au labrador
et ce qui fait en sorte que me voulu
mettre à l'eau c'était que de la glace
les lacs étaient gelés il a donc fallu
qu'on tire nos canaux sa grâce pendant
plus de cent kilomètres le pendant les
deux premières semaines de l'expédition
[Musique]
après on est arrivé vraiment dans une
georges qui était un très très grand cru
ça crée des murs de glace de jusqu'à 10
mètres de haut
on pouvait pas sortir la rivière qui en
voulait
à l'avant j'avais repéré des points où
il y avait de la poussière aly kane qui
est l'écosystème qui ne s'intéressaient
ou ce cas là on fallait qu'on débarque
fallait qu'on prenne le temps de
s'arrêter sortir les chiottes sortir les
haches récolter des rondelles darde puis
après ce médecin dans nos canaux alors
en plus à chaque fois on devrait être
plus en plus l'eau on a remonté la coque
est la cover aussi est en crue alors
monté 130 km de rivières grande crue où
on avait beaucoup beaucoup de portage et
main sur la coloc on ne s'est pas
découragée on voulait échantillonnés
deux forêts qui est vraiment deux
écosystème exceptionnel
[Musique]
les moments les plus difficiles ont été
sur la côte basque on dormait plus d'une
très grande densité ours polaire sur la
côte de l'océan atlantique
et s'il faisait en sorte qu'on faisait
continuellement des vigies dont il
fallait toujours garder une personne
réveiller serais-tu par poté journée
titre pagaie dans l'océan 30 40 50 km
dans les vagues dans le vent dans la mer
littéralement il ya des baleines des
icebergs autour de toi
le soir où au lieu d'aller te coucher si
tu fais des tours de garde autour de la
tendance à penser qu'on était vraiment
vraiment infuse et guillaume moreau a
visiblement la satisfaction du devoir
accompli sans aucun doute sans aucune
hésitation de tout le monde on a réussi
à récolter ce qu'on voulait des
champions bois les bûchettes sont
maintenant analysées en laboratoire
chacun de leurs cercles de croissance et
comptabilisés les résultats encore
partiels bien sûr sont plutôt étonnants
zorman à les dernières années on aime
chute de croissance dans ses sables
malgré l'augmentation des températures
on a une chute de croissance
alors on se demande pourquoi puis on
pense que c'est relié à des événements
extrêmes justement comme des dégel qui
peuvent survenir de manière hâtive au
printemps avec un bib gourmand possible
donc une reprise la croissance suivie de
gel intense mais c'est un phénomène
récent
apparu il ya une dizaine d'années
seulement la tendance plus encore
s'inverser
il ne faut pas sauter trop vite aux
conclusions il faut faire attention
parce qu'effectivement si on regarde sur
une longue période
on voit quand même dans le début des
années 1900 et une augmentation de la
croissance des arbres
[Musique]
le fait que les arbres grandissent moins
vite ces dernières années peut remettre
en question notre façon de relier le
climat à la croissance des arbres le
lien entre la taille des cernes annuel
du bois et la température ambiante n'est
peut-être pas aussi simple qu'on croyait
ses relations le évolué dans le temps
mais si on veut utiliser la croissance
des arbres pour reconstituer les climats
passés va falloir tenir compte aussi de
cette évolution là
[Musique]
oui ça va nous permettre de faire
avancer la science et des échantillons
de qualité ce n'est pas pour rien que
leur présence à l'inversé aval on est
une grosse équipe qui travaille qui
travaillent on a justement analysé ces
données là c'est parce que ya un très
grand potentiel pour améliorer nos
connaissances l'impact des changements
climatiques sur les écosystèmes
nordiques et même les un costume plus
haut
[Musique]
l'expédition de 2018 a laissé guillaume
moreau sur sa faim il se prépare donc
avec un autre chercheur les deux
enseignants à traverser le canada
du nord au sud ils auront sept mois pour
parcourir 8000 km en ski en canot et en
vélo
bon courage